over watches hardcore scene is booming
but things are changing a bit for season
3 i'm tony and this is your competitive
game spot news update first the time
between seasons is shrinking so the
downtime will only be a week long season
2 ends on november 24th and season 3
kicks off on december first skill
ratings and skill tier placement is also
being revamped your skill rating won't
completely reset in between seasons but
you might not be in the same tier you
were in before whether that was bronze
silver gold platinum or any of the super
high ranks this is because blizzard
wound up with way more players in the
gold and platinum tears than expected so
when you start playing season 3 in
December don't be surprised to see your
skill rating a little lower than where
you left it these changes are live on
blizzard's public test realm right now
so download that from battlenet if you
want to give them a go you'll also get
to try out the games next character
first whenever she finally gets
announced for all the latest overwatch
news you're already in the right place
you